en la conferencia de prensa conjunta que
mantuvieron con el presidente Alberto
Fernández fanda Legend hizo especial
hincapié en que la Unión Europea es el
principal inversor extranjero directo en
Argentina tiene un 40% de las
inversiones extranjeras directas en el
país y que la Unión Europea está
interesada en invertir aún más aquí en
el país y también en América Latina hizo
especial referencia a las energías
limpias al cobre
también mencionó el hidrógeno verde y
sobre todo el litio un metal estratégico
que Argentina tiene del que Argentina
tiene grandes reservas en el Noroeste
del país reservas que interesan a
inversores de Estados Unidos de Europa y
de China por igual También discutieron
el tema del acuerdo entre la Unión
Europea y el mercosur allí el presidente
Alberto Fernández refirió que Argentina
necesita revisar algunos puntos sobre
todo lo que tiene que ver con políticas
proteccionistas de Europa referentes a
los sectores como los agropecuarios que
pueden afectar a los productores
argentinos
que está interesada en que se pueda
llegar a un acuerdo para resolver las
diferencias antes de fines de este año